foreign
quickly passing drop ceiling to indicate
someone is being wheeled through a
hospital cliche
yeah damn it stop showing me needles
going into people's skins I can infer
sedation I can inverse it Asian having a
discount Lucille in your trunk as if
that's a normal thing
quickly throwing a door wide open to an
area you've been told holds a cat-eating
lizard monster forgetting to cover up
your Escape hole with a poster of
whatever the demogorgon version of
Raquel Welch is oh [__] I hope all the
characters have the girati and
Razorbacks equipped continuing to use
flashlights to do your search work
instead of turning on the house lights
this guy sure committed to the
atmosphere of the show huh
can a person in this room tell
not in the room but I can take a whack
at this you see Joyce The Duffer
Brothers had an unexpected Smash Hit in
season one and because Netflix likes
money more than Mr Krabs they were told
to quickly make a season two they didn't
know how to create additional conflict
without once again using will as their
pin cushion of suffering so that's
what's wrong with your boy the writers
didn't want to have Mike Dustin or Lucas
suffer this season you see why I have to
stop the truth from spreading too using
a high-speed dubbing deck to dub things
at not high speed you've got chemistry
history Plus
the real
shared trauma thinking that trauma
bonding is the ultimate foundation for a
successful relationship there's a
pull-out sofa in my study if you want
trusting the pull out sofa method
pullout sofas have been scientifically
shown to only have about 80 sleep
Effectiveness he does this for a couple
of hours these guys all figured out this
Nancy Jonathan Steve love triangle
[__] goes on for all the some season
after season time allowing this much
light to come through the window
overnight quit being so distracted by
your lady boner Nancy and get some more
protection on that thing to keep
unwanted streams from penetrating
through I may also be distracted hey
they're in love No actually they're not
they
the hell is that
something you should see trying to
camouflage or better come take a look at
this cliche as a here put this on and
then you better come take a look at this
cliche it's been spreading
growing beneath us like some cancer Tick
Tock man
we thought stuff like this happen in
movies and comic books Mikey
conveniently forgets to mention that it
also happens in television shows from
Desperate streaming companies who are
starting to realize that all the money
they threw around me not be coming back
to them anytime soon kind of makes my
idea of moving to Maine sound a little
less crazy right come on Bob pet
cemetery's been out for an entire year
by this point read it and rethink the
main thing we sent a TV sins writer up
there once to see what it was like she
never returned is there a doctor we need
a doctor not installing a call button in
the room of your patient suffering from
a mysterious metaphysical related
ailments so
Jonathan
that was the pull out stop being a
pervert Murray here's five cents for
being lame enough to make a bull out
joke can you imagine
oops treating the wasting of food and
the resulting growing epidemic of Global
Food scarcity so casually for your
travels offering a gift of vodka to your
underage friends and encouraging it to
be for their travels as if having him
smoking during his workout wasn't enough
Billy snags a magic beer out of thin air
on his way to the door to really drive
home what an 80s bad boy he really is
leaving your window open for absolutely
no reason whatsoever if you come back to
a room filled with the local Wildlife
throwing a kegger don't blame me Max you
remember me
man we'll forgot Hopper even faster than
Hopper forgot that Hellboy film he was
in he said upset him
is that him yes it's convenient that he
just happens to have this picture at the
ready but more importantly this is
terrible evidence worked by the
photographers each picture should be
photographed separately on a dark
background not thrown on top of each
other like some sort of scrapbooking
project
s where
unhelpful answers come on will it's not
like the show just uses you as a trauma
magnet grow up what happens when my boy
is gone you basically lose your mind and
turn into a single-minded wrecking ball
of emotion did you not see yourself in
season one Joyce the Kiwi girls just
just acting like you don't care weird I
thought that was the key with waving
your arms in the air now whoa whoa whoa
slow down Romeo I really hope Steven's
about to teach Dustin about the
importance of consent that's going to be
awesome Faberge what is Faberge Organics
one of the greatest choices this show
made was letting these two cook together
take your sin off for the birth of Steve
Hopper's desperately trying to contact
11 here because even the characters in
the show realize the audience has been
bored without her around for the last 30
minutes I always start to get sleepy
around half past 11. just make sure you
heat up some real food okay not just
Eggos how dare you Hopper serving of
egos contains 20 of your daily intake of
calcium iron and vitamin A and oh no
this was a trap to get me to defend egos
wasn't it we have bigger problems than
the boy agree Brahms the boy too was
much worse but I'm not sure what this
has to do with anything doctors take
forever always that's why they call us
patience
look guys this section's boring I'm just
trying my best these two have been
spreading meat John it's like the only
creature that would possibly follow this
Trail is the demogorgon but it's
honestly much more likely that the
climax of this episode should have
featured a turkey vulture putting tax
through your jaws poster get that thing
in a frame you post or Fiend I don't
shoot Polaroid what it's not mine they
left behind a Polaroid cartridge who are
these idiots and why do their brains run
on script convenience synchronized
Barrel rolling of all the ridiculous
things these kids managed to do in this
short of time getting all these tires up
there is the ridiculousest those suckers
are heavy at some point before now they
would have been tired enough to stop and
realize they were already tired enough
don't be an idiot okay it wasn't a bear
that's good
just sure you don't care there's a
difference between negging and just
being an [__] hold on reconsidering
nope I take it back there is no
difference but Dustin was still being an
[__] and Dustin the [__] is my
least favorite Dustin my mom
and my stepdad they wanted
[Music]
bragging about having eyes what a silly
thing to say it's not like the show's
gonna take the eyes of one of its main
characters can you imagine see what are
you doing
just get ready and that's all I'm gonna
say about that right now because I
wouldn't want to give anything away to
the audience yet it would taste better
than cat I promise making promises
without the proper experiential
knowledge I hope
being this confident in your school bus
Fort unless you see Miss Frizzle
somewhere in there your bus ain't [__]
what's up
hey you sex
um Deus Ex
Deus Ex I guess is that satisfying
doesn't it just completely undo this
entire Bland uh the plan to
this plot line was all the pointless huh
they're going somewhere oh oh I want to
play
they'll arrive at a place they're gonna
be near stuff see I can say vague too
you can tell this is going to go
extremely well because this is the one
time they sent an entire team down
without a single character we really
know I bet I could even tell you what
color shirts they're wearing under those
hazmat suits I'm sorry hey save your
apologies for the Chicago episode that's
what this season truly needs to
apologize for
and for some reason is letting me tell
you this now when I couldn't earlier he
said something about extending the
dramatic tension a spy the spot roll
commercials roll commercials
well you have bad hair
no no I mean we're just friends friends
men and women can't be friends because
the sex part always gets in the way
the boys pheromone level suggests he
wants to mate with the female
that's my friend
Mike what about me kid you couldn't
forget my face could you do a barrel
roll Lucas what's going on hold on
three o'clock three o'clock
clever girl
here's Johnny